hello support in Hollywood we have many
words for it
alimony a carton of cigarettes sent to a
rehab facility
I wonder bra none of that applies to
these five gifted women whose
performances are in themselves a
masterful definition of support they are
the foundation on which so much of their
movies are built so in the category of
Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role the nominees are
jennifer connelly in a beautiful mind
Alan mirror the lustful part
Maggie Smith the gospel park
Marisa Tomei and in the bedroom
Kate Winslet in iris
and the Oscar goes to Jennifer Connelly
a beautiful mind
this is Jennifer Connelly's
she made her screen to view
hello okay
I brought paper because I didn't want to
forget um thank you to the members of
the Academy for this honor by some
beautiful twist of fate I've landed in
this vocation that demands that I feel
and helps that helps me to learn and no
film has moved or taught me more than a
beautiful mind thank you to all of our
magnificent cast and crew for their
invaluable collaboration and most
especially to Ron Howard and to Russell
Crowe thanks to all the artists who have
inspired me and the list is too long
thanks to my dearest ones who give me
love and support
risa satou pyro Keri Ross my family and
friends I believe in love that there's
nothing more important Alesha Nash is a
true champion of love and so thank you
to her for her example my son Kai is for
me the greatest messenger and so thank
you to him for all of our days thank you
very much